สวัสดีค่ะครูนี้สวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนทุกคนโอเคเดี๋ยวเราเขียนวันที่ก่อน
คุณนิควันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันพุธครับ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 3 ครับ
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนสิงหาคมครับปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะมี
เวลากี่โมงคะ
ตอนนี้นะครับเมืองที่คุณนิดอยู่เนี่ยเวลา
8 โมง 56 นาทีค่ะ
แล้ว
เมืองที่ผู้หญิงอยู่กี่โมงครับเมืองที่
ครูหญิงอยู่ก็เร็วกว่าครูนิดหนึ่งชั่วโมง
ก็เป็น 9 โมง 56 นาทีตอนเช้าเหมือนกัน
สบายดีนะคะ
คุณนิคสบายดีสบายดีครับแค่ช่วงนี้ช่วงนี้
รู้สึกรู้สึกไม่รู้เป็นอะไรมันปวดตา
ใช่ครับ
[เพลง]
ประมาณ 1 ชั่วโมง 2 ชั่วโมง
คือคุณนี้จะไม่รู้ว่าเป็นเพราะอะไรอาจจะ
เป็นเพราะแสงหรืออะไรไม่รู้
สัก 1 ชั่วโมงใช่ไหมคะก็จะดีขึ้นแล้วก็
หายไป
มันก็จะค่อยๆดีขึ้นคือคุณนี้ก็คิดว่าอาจ
จะตาคุณนิคเนี่ยมันยังทำงานช้านิดหน่อย
หรือเปล่า
มันตื่นไม่ดีเหมือนกันยังไม่มีกาแฟ
ใช่ๆค่ะบางครั้งเราก็แบบเอ๊ะเราตื่นหรือ
ยัง
แต่ว่าส่วนอื่นก็สบายดีแล้วก็สบายดี
ผู้หญิงสบายดีไหมครับ
ผู้หญิงก็สบายดีค่ะไม่ได้มีปัญหาอะไรก็
อาจจะแบบมันเช้าเนอะเราอัดวีดีโอกันเช้าๆ
บางครั้งเราก็อาจจะยังตื่นไม่ 100% นะคะ
ได้ค่ะแต่ว่า
ตอนนี้ก็จะมาคิดว่าวิดีโอนี้เนี่ยเรื่อง
ที่ผู้หญิงจะมาคุยเนี่ยนะคะก็อาจจะทำให้
คุณนิคเนี่ย
ตื่นตื่นได้แหละ
[เพลง]
นะคะเพราะว่า
ถ้าใจก็คือเขาเรียกทายใจไหมน่าจะทายใจนะ
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยจะมีคำถามให้คุณนิคเล่นนะคะ
แล้วพอเล่นเสร็จแล้วก็จะบอกว่าเอ่อครูนิค
เนี่ยเป็นคนแบบไหนก็ไม่เชิงไทยใจนะไม่ใช่
ทายใจผู้หญิงพูดผิดขอโทษค่ะ
แต่เขาจะเรียกว่าอะไรเออจริงๆเราก็จะบอก
ว่าไทยนิสัยเอ้อ
ทายนิสัยใช่ไหมเพราะว่าเราให้เขาเลือก
แล้วก็ดูว่าถ้าคุณเลือกแบบนี้คุณจะเป็นคน
นิสัยแบบนี้
เราจะมีให้คุณนิคเล่นนะคะนักเรียนอยาก
เล่นด้วยก็ได้แต่ว่านักเรียนอาจจะไม่ได้
รู้ว่าเป็นยังไงเพราะว่ามันมีคำตอบเวลา
เล่นเสร็จแล้วเนี่ยวันนี้เยอะนะคะก็มาใช้
นิสัยว่าครูนิคเป็นคนยังไงดีกว่าผู้หญิง
คำถามเนี่ยจะมี 4 ข้อนะคะคุณนิแต่ว่าเวลา
คุยหญิงถามข้อที่ 1
เสร็จแล้วแล้วเวลาคุณนิดตอบให้คุณนิด
เขียนตัวเลขตัวเลขมันจะมีแค่ 1 กับ 2
4 ข้อเนี่ยคุณนี้ก็จะมีตัวเลข 1  2  3  4
4 ตัวเลขนะก็มี
111222-1212 อะไรอย่างเงี้ยอ่าใช่
เอามือขึ้นมา 2 ข้างนะคะแล้วก็เอามือ
เนี่ยประสานกัน
แล้วก็ดูว่าครูนิคเนี่ยนิ้วโป้งนะคะนิ้ว
โป้งซ้าย
ทับนิ้วโป้งขวาหรือนิ้วโป้งขวาทับนิ้ว
ประสานมือคุณนิดต้องเอาให้ผู้หญิงดูด้วย
ไหม
ถ้าดูได้ค่ะดูได้
ของคู่นี้ก็จะเป็น
นิ้วโป้งขวาทับนิ้วโป้งซ้าย
ถ้าครูนิคเนี่ยนิ้วโป้งขวาทับนิ้วโป้ง
ซ้ายให้คนนี้เขียนเลข 2
ใส่แต่ถ้านักเรียนนะนักเรียนเนี่ยนิ้ว
โป้งซ้ายทับนิ้วโป้งขวาให้นักเรียนเขียน
เลข 1 นะคะ
[เพลง]
ขาดหายไปแต่ก็ไม่เป็นไรหรอกครับก็ยัง
สว่าง
โอเคได้ครับ
ข้อที่ 2 นะคะข้อที่ 2 ให้คุณนิคทำทำมือ
เหมือนยิงปืนผู้หญิงอย่างนี้ค่ะ
ใส่แล้วก็ให้คุณนิคเนี่ยเล็งสมัยเวลาเล็ง
เนี่ยครูนิคเนี่ยหลับตาข้างไหน
[เพลง]
ถ้าครูนิคหลับตาข้างขวานะคะให้เขียนเลข 1
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยหลับตาข้างซ้าย
ก็คุณนิดเขียนเลข 1 นะคะแต่ถ้าข้างซ้ายก็
เลข 2
ข้อที่ 3 นะคะข้อที่ 3 ให้คุณนิดทำท่า
ก่อนอบแล้ว
[เพลง]
ก็ดูว่าถ้า
แขนแขนข้างไหนเนี่ย
แขนข้างซ้ายอยู่ข้างบน
แขนข้างซ้ายอยู่ข้างบนก็คู่นี้ก็เขียนเลข
แขนซ้ายอยู่ข้างบนแต่ถ้า
แขนขวาแขนขวาอยู่ข้างบนก็เขียนเลข 2
กดอีกสายใช่ไหมคะ
แล้วก็ข้อสุดท้ายนะคะปรบมือแต่ไม่ๆปรบมือ
แบบนี้นะปรบมือแบบนี้
[เพลง]
ก็ได้หรอ
เวลาปรบมือเนี่ย
มือข้างไหนอยู่ข้างบน
เวลาเรากดมือ
ของคุณ
นิดก็คิดว่า
[เพลง]
มือซ้ายครับ
ถ้ามือซ้ายอยู่ข้างบนก็เขียนเลข 1 นะคะ
แต่ถ้ามือขวาหรือขวาอยู่ข้างบนก็เขียนเลข
อะไรที่เป็นมือซ้ายบ่อยแต่บางครั้งบาง
อย่างคุณนี้ก็ใช้มือขวา
ก็เลยพยายามคิดว่าส่วนใหญ่พวกนี้ทำอะไร
แล้วนี่จะถ่ายนิสัยครูนิดตรงไหมเนี่ยว่า
ครูนิเป็นคนแบบไหน
[เพลง]
มันต้องเอาเอาเป็นแบบว่าความรู้สึกแรก
เนอะเวลาครูหญิงให้ครุยทำแล้วแบบมันขึ้น
มาเลยอ่ะอันนั้นอาจจะ
ตรงที่สุด
แต่นี่มันก็เป็นเกมทายทายนิสัยอ่ะนะคะมัน
ไม่ได้ตรง 100%
หมดแล้วค่ะครบแล้ว 4 ข้อครูนิคได้เลข 4
ตัวแล้วคนนี้ได้เลขอะไรคะของครูนี้
ได้เลข 2
แล้วก็ 1
1 เดี๋ยวขอผู้หญิง
เป็นคนที่
น่าเชื่อถือ
เพราะว่านักเรียนอะไรคะ
ไม่ต้องคิดว่าคุณนิดพูดจริงหรือว่าคุณนิ
โกหกหรือว่าจริงหรือว่าคุณนิโกหกไม่ใช่
คือ
ได้ 100% ใช่ค่ะ
ถ้าเกิดเป็นเพื่อนกันจะชอบแกล้งแต่ก็ถ้า
เป็นเรื่องที่มันซีเรียสจริงๆเนี่ยคนนี้
ก็จะพูดความจริงนะว่าเออเขาก็จะได้เชื่อ
แต่ถ้าเป็นเรื่องที่มันไร้สาระเนี่ยคุณก็
จะแกล้งบ่อย
ใช่แต่ถ้าสมมติเป็นครูใช่ไหมสอนนักเรียน
หรือว่า
หรือว่าแบบเวลาเราเราอาจจะมองดูก็ได้อ่ะ
ค่ะว่าเออคนๆนี้คนที่อาจจะไม่ได้พูดก็ได้
แต่เวลาเห็นแล้วเนี่ยรู้สึกว่าคนๆนี้ดูดู
พูดอะไรแล้วเชื่อได้นะนี่คือเป็นคนน่า
เชื่อถือนะคะดีนะคะเนี่ย
เป็นคนที่จะมาแป๊บนึงเพราะคุณ
ส้มเกินไปนะ
เดี๋ยวนักเรียนจะรู้สึกว่าหน้าส้มไปหรือ
เปล่าดูไม่น่าเชื่อถือหรอคะ
ผู้หญิงก็เหลือถ้าผู้หญิงไม่มีไฟแล้วก็
คุณนิคส้มแล้วผู้หญิงเหลืองนักเรียนอาจจะ
คิดว่าเอ๊ะอยู่ที่ไหนนะคะคนนึงส้มคนนึง
เหลือ
ตอนนี้ดีขึ้นแล้ว
สีเท่าๆกัน
เนาะคุณนิเป็นคนน่าเชื่อถือนะคะแล้วเขาก็
บอกว่าข้อนี้ยาวนะคะคุณนิคเนี่ยเป็นคนที่
ชอบทำงาน
ตรงไหมคะชอบทำงานไหมชอบทำงานไหมชอบครับ
เพราะว่าคุณนี่ก็เป็นคน
คือสำหรับคุณนี้เนี่ยคุณนิ้งเป็นคนเบื่อ
ง่ายเหมือนกับถ้าอยู่เฉยๆมันไม่มีอะไรทำ
ไงคนที่จะคุณไม่ชอบคุณนิดชอบทำงานเพราะ
ว่ามันพอทำงานน่ะมันฆ่าเวลาได้เร็ว
เวลาก็ผ่านหมดไปแล้ว 1 วัน
คือแล้วก็ทำงานมันได้เงิน
ก็เลยแต่มันก็ยังมีคนที่แบบว่าไม่รู้นะ
ว่าทำงานน่ะได้เงินแต่แบบมีความรู้สึกแบบ
วันนี้ฉันต้องตื่นมาทำงานอีกแล้วหรอ
คนก็มีน้ำไม่ชอบทำงานแต่คุณนิ
แต่ผู้หญิงดูผู้หญิงก็รู้เออคนนี้ก็ดู
เป็นคนชอบทำงานนะดูแบบทำงานเยอะอ่ะเออคือ
ตอนนี้เนี่ยครูนิดทำงานเยอะเนี่ยมันเพราะ
ว่าคือคุณนิใช้คำว่ามันชินมากกว่าเพราะ
พ่อทำงานน้อยลงคุณเลยรู้สึกว่าเอ้ยมันไม่
ใช่
มันไม่มีอะไรทำคือถ้าเมื่อก่อนเนี่ย
คุณมิกซ์ตอนที่ทำงานอยู่สายการบินคุณนิด
ก็ทำงานเยอะนะแล้วพอมีเวลาว่างมากๆคุณก็
จะไปเที่ยวก็คือจะไม่ให้ตัวเองอยู่กับที่
เฉยๆเหมือนกับแบบหยุด 3 วันนอนอยู่บ้าน
ไม่ทำอะไรเงี้ยคุณนึกจะรู้สึกแปลกๆแล้ว
ก็คือชอบชอบมีกิจกรรมด้วยอ่ะเนาะใช่
ทำงานก็ทำงานก็ด้วยก็โอเคครับใช้คำว่าชอบ
ทำงานก็ได้แต่กลัวว่าพอพูดถึงทำงานเนี่ย
บางคนจะบอกว่าบ้านงานหรือเปล่า
แต่คุณยังไม่ถึงไม่ถึงนะอันนี้แต่
สิ่งที่แบบที่เขาเขียนนะว่าแบบตัวเลขที่
คุณนิดได้ใช่ไหมก็คือเป็นคนชอบทำงานแต่
ไม่ได้เป็นคนบ้านงานเพราะว่าดูได้จากคุณ
นิดบอกว่าเมื่อก่อนตอนคุณนิกทำงานเยอะพอ
วันหยุดคุณนิจะเที่ยว
แต่ถ้าคนที่บ้านงานเนี่ยนะคะ
ก็คือทำงานแบบไม่มีวันหยุดอ่ะใช่อันนั้น
อันนั้นมันมากเกินไปอันนั้นคือบ้านงาน
อีกหนึ่งข้อนะคะอันนี้ไม่รู้ตรงหรือไม่
ตรงนะผู้หญิงพูดแล้วครูนิดบอกได้นะคะเขา
บอกว่าคุณน่ะก็จะเป็นคนที่เขาบอกว่าเป็น
คนที่ไม่ขอความช่วยเหลือจากใครก็คือเป็น
คนที่แบบเวลาทำอะไรแล้วถ้าทำไม่ได้
ก็จะไม่บอกว่าเธอผู้หญิงผู้หญิงช่วยคุณ
นิดหน่อยได้ไหมเนี่ยคุณนิทำไม่ได้คุณนิด
ก็จะไม่ไม่ขอความช่วยเหลือจากใครคือเวลา
ทำอะไรไม่ได้ก็จะพยายามทำเองทำเองทำเอง
[เพลง]
จริงไหม
ก็ก็ตรง
ก็ตรงนะ
ใช่ก็ตรงคนนี้ใช้คำว่าตรงประมาณ
80% ละกันเพราะว่าถ้ามันเป็นอะไรที่คุณ
ต้องทำแล้วมันใหม่เป็นครั้งแรกที่ทำคุณ
นิดก็จะให้เขาช่วยเพราะว่าเราแค่อยากรู้
ว่าถ้าเกิดว่าเขาช่วยแล้วโอเคแบบนี้แหละ
ถูกต้องแล้วเราตามหลังจากนั้นจะไม่ขอความ
ช่วยเหลือแล้วก็เหมือนแบบทำเองได้เขาไม่
ได้เรียกว่าทำไม่ได้อันนี้ไม่ใช่เป็นคน
ที่คิดว่าตัวเองเก่งนะคะแต่หมายถึงว่า
เป็นคนที่ชอบทำอะไรด้วยตัวเอง
แต่ที่คุณนิดคุณนี้เป็นแบบนั้นเนี่ยเพราะ
ว่าคุณนี่แค่ถ้าเกิดว่าให้คนอื่นให้คน
อื่นช่วยเนี่ยมันเหมือนกับยกตัวอย่างว่า
เขาก็มีเรื่องต้องทำอยู่แล้วเขาก็ยุ่ง
อยู่แล้วแล้วบางทีถ้าเราขอความช่วยเหลือ
จากเขาเนี่ยมันอาจจะเป็นแค่เรื่องเล็กๆ
ที่ไม่จำเป็นต้องขอใครก็ได้เราต้องลองทำ
เองก่อนถ้ามันแย่จริงๆมันไม่ดีจริงๆเราก็
เลยเราก็จะขอว่าเออช่วยหน่อยว่าเนี่ยไม่
แน่ใจว่าที่ทำมันถูกไหม
ก็จะเป็นแบบนั้นมากกว่าสำหรับคุณนิดแต่
ถึงบอกว่ามันก็ตรงประมาณ 80% ว่าถ้าทำเอง
ได้ก็จะไม่ขอให้ใครมาช่วย
เราก็จะเขาเรียกอะไรอ่ะหาด้วยตัวเองก่อน
อาจจะเสิร์ชจากอินเทอร์เน็ตหาจาก Google
ก่อนแล้วถ้าแบบมันไม่ได้จริงๆโอเคค่อยถาม
ค่อยขอความช่วยเหลือจากคนอื่นอันนี้ก็คือ
ทายนิสัยของครูนิคจัดตัวเลข 2  1  1  1
ก็ตรงนะเอาจริงๆ
น่าเชื่อถือเนี่ยคืออันแรกที่ผู้หญิงบอก
ว่าเป็นคนที่เชื่อถือ
คุณนี้ก็เคยได้ยินเพื่อนหรือคนที่คุณ
เรียนรู้จักเขาก็บอกว่าตอนแรกๆเนี่ยที่
เขาเจอคุณนิดครั้งแรกเนี่ยเขาบอกว่าดูจาก
ท่าทางการพูดเขาก็มองว่าคุณนิคเนี่ยเป็น
คนที่เหมือนกับพูดอะไรแล้วมันจริงจังพูด
แล้วคนไทยจะบอกว่าอะไรมันมีน้ำหนักอ่ะ
ข้อมูลหรือหาอะไรมาเหมือนกับมาช่วย
support มาสนับสนุนได้ว่าเออมันน่าเชื่อ
ถือนะ
ผู้หญิงก็คิดเหมือนกันแบบคุณนิกบอกกับการ
ไปเป็นครูมากๆเลยหรือเราเรียกว่าอาจารย์
อย่างนี้นักเรียนคิดถึงความน่าเชื่อถือ
คิดถึงคนที่เป็นครูสอนสอนนักเรียนในแบบ
มหาวิทยาลัยอย่างนี้แบบทำงานแบบเด็กอายุ
19  20  21  22 อย่างนั้นน่ะค่ะเวลาเรา
เรียนมหาวิทยาลัยใช่ไหมเรียน High  School
จบแล้วอ่ะคุณนิกอ่ะเหมือน
คนที่แบบมีบุคลิกแบบเออดูที่ว่าพูดอะไร
แล้วรู้สึกว่า
คนนี้ดูเชื่อได้เชื่อได้อ่าดูดูเป็นคนที่
คิดมาแล้วหาข้อมูลมาแล้วว่าสิ่งที่จะพูด
เนี่ยมันจริงอ่า
ใช่ก็แต่พอหลังจากนั้นเนี่ยคนส่วนใหญ่ก็
พอรู้จักคุณที่นานๆเขาจะเอ๊ะ
เขาต้องคิดเยอะๆแล้วว่าที่คุณพูดเนี่ย
จริงหรือไม่จริงเพราะว่าคือหลายคนจะบอก
ว่าคุณครับเป็นคนหน้าตาอย่างเป็นคนหน้า
ตายพูดอะไรเนี่ยเขาจะดูไม่ค่อยออกว่าเล่น
หรือไม่เล่นเออคุณนิจะเล่าให้ฟังมันเคยมี
อยู่ 1 ครั้งคืออันนี้คือคุณนิดก็ทำงาน
กับเพื่อนในบนเครื่องบินด้วยกันแล้วก็
อยู่ด้วยกันนี่แหละแล้วคุณนิดเป็นหัวหน้า
เป็นหัวหน้าในเที่ยวบินนั้นแล้วเพื่อนคุณ
นิคเหมือนกับเขา
เทวานใส่แก้วแต่ใส่แก้วที่มันมันไม่ใช่
แก้วมันเหมือนเป็นแก้วพลาสติก
ใช่เพราะว่าเขาจะเอาไปให้ในให้ผู้โดยสาร
ในฉันอีกคนนึงนี่ค่ะว่าคุณนิดก็บอกว่าเออ
ไม่ต้องเอาแก้วพลาสติกหรอกใส่แก้วที่เป็น
แก้วก็ได้
เขาก็เอาไวน์จากแก้วพลาสติกเทใส่แก้วแก้ว
จริงๆ
ก็เลยแกล้งเขาแต่คนนี้ก็ทำได้นิ่งๆบอกว่า
เฮ้ยทำอย่างนี้มันไม่ได้นะจะต้องเทจากขวด
อันใหม่ให้เขาเพราะว่าเนี่ยเอาจากแก้ว
พลาสติกเทใส่แก้วจริงๆอ่ะรสชาติของวัยมัน
จะเปลี่ยน
จากอร่อยเป็นไม่อร่อยแล้วพูดโดยสารถ้าเขา
กินไวน์เนี่ยเขาจะรู้ว่ามันมีอะไรมันผิด
ปกติ
แต่คุณนี่แกล้งเขานะ
ทำหน้านิ่งๆเพื่อนคุณนิดก็มอง
มันก็น่าจะเป็นไปได้เพราะว่าเออมันก็น่า
จะใช่เพราะว่าแก้วพลาสติกแก้วแก้วแล้วก็
เทมันมีอากาศที่ทำให้เปลี่ยนได้
เขาก็เชื่อแล้วเขาก็เททิ้งแล้วก็เอาจาก
ขวดแบบเทใส่ให้ผู้โดยสารใหม่แล้วพอคุณ
เห็นแล้วหัวเราะหรือว่าทำอะไรไว้ให้เขา
รู้ว่าคุณนี่แกล้งวันนี้ก็หัวเราะ
ราคาก็บอกว่าโอ๊ย
โดนแกล้งอีกแล้ว
[เพลง]
นั่นแหละ
แต่ถึงแม้ว่าเพื่อนก็จะรู้ว่าครูนิดชอบ
แกล้งแต่เพื่อนยังคิด
จะจริงนะคะ
ก็เป็นเกมที่สนุกดีถ่าย
นิสัยนะคะแต่ว่านักเรียนเนี่ยตัวเลขอะไร
เนี่ยคือผู้หญิงไม่รู้ไงมันมีตัวเล็กเยอะ
มากๆบอกทั้งหมดน่าจะเวลาไม่พอนะคะมารู้
จักครูนิดละกันนะคะว่าครูนี้เป็นคนนิสัย
แบบไหนแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้วเนาะ
เดี๋ยวเรามาเจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้านะไว้
เจอกันใหม่ในวีดีโอหน้าครับผู้หญิงค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะ